in 1973 oregon became the first state to
decriminalize marijuana use setting in
motion a movement that has led to the
unraveling of the disastrous u.s drug
war with far-reaching consequences we
must wage what i have called total war
against public enemy number one in the
united states the problem of dangerous
drugs no one goes to jail
no longer are our jails being occupied
by young people that have done nothing
more than smoke marijuana and have
committed no other criminal offense
today oregon is once again at the
vanguard of reform in february it
enacted a law ending prison sentences
for all types of drug use and possession
whether it be cocaine meth heroin or
psychedelics in 2019 before this new law
was passed in a statewide referendum
more than 4 000 people were convicted of
drug possession in oregon and many more
cut deals with prosecutors allowing them
to avoid a conviction in exchange for
supervised probation and some rehab with
the new law not only does possession
bring nothing more than a hundred dollar
ticket defendants can get them dismissed
if they place just one phone call to a
drug abuse assessment hotline so far
only 29 people ticketed for possession
have placed that call according to the
non-profit that runs the hotline the
lack of accountability built into the
measure that would be my concern is that
we see a bunch of money in the system
that isn't having an effect mike
marshall who has a personal history with
alcoholism and meth use is executive
director of organ recovers which lobbies
for more funding for addiction treatment
and opposed measure 110. i'm worried
about the person living on the street in
the tent right outside this window who's
smoking meth all day long and they're
destroying their system we need to to
have a system of care to take care of
them marshall believes oregon should
have more closely followed the example
of portugal the first country to
decriminalize all drugs it spent two
years building a more robust treatment
system before decriminalization went
into effect we have to learn our own set
of lessons now because we chose to
ignore the lessons that were available
to us portugal also required those
caught with drugs to appear before a
special committee of doctors and
addiction specialists oregon's new law
does require the state allocate at least
57 million dollars in its first year to
establish a comprehensive substance
abuse treatment system that offers
immediate rehab the state legislature
awarded 20 million dollars in grants to
treatment providers in june and approved
spending 302 million over the next 20
years on substance abuse treatment but
today oregon which has the third largest
addiction problem in the nation is 47th
in addiction treatment access and the
introduction of the synthetic opioid
fentanyl into the black market has made
street drug use deadlier than ever with
an estimated 36 000 nationwide deaths
involving the drug in 2019 and
increasing by as much as 38 with the
onset of the pandemic according to the
cdc marshall says the state should have
bolstered its treatment infrastructure
before moving forward with
decriminalization we hugely support
decriminalization the notion of
criminalizing someone's addiction is
terrible particularly when we know that
humans of color disproportionately
arrested for drugs so decriminalization
is hugely important but how you do
decriminalization is equally important
he points out that an earlier
decriminalization measure already allows
judges to divert drug offenders to
treatment but believes that removing the
threat of arrest takes away a vital tool
for getting drug addicts the help that
they need if somebody down on the street
on january 30th was using and a cop saw
them and so busted them for having drugs
out in the open they ended up in jail
they then went to the court so there was
a weeks period of time where their drug
use was interrupted versus the cop now
just walking right by or giving them a
ticket and walking on by and they
continue drugs
the war on people who use drugs has
not been fruitful
haven wheelock runs a needle exchange in
portland called outside in she says
delaying decriminalization would have
been morally unacceptable anything we do
is better than doing nothing we know the
harms of criminalization are harming
people on the regular we know that these
interactions between law enforcement and
people who are using drugs can be deadly
and so for me decriminalizing drugs is a
priority in and of itself those harms
are real those harms are happening today
we want to interrupt that prison cycle
and offer services instead which any
doctor
or clinical person would be recommending
rather than prison monteneuton is the
executive director of bridges to change
which helps drug offenders who've
recently been released from jail or
prison transition into housing like this
and reintegrate into society bridges to
change is one of several non-profits
that will receive additional money
through measure 110 financed by
marijuana taxes to provide services to
drug users before they enter the
criminal justice system knudsen says
that some chronic drug users don't need
the threat of prison just easier access
to treatment and so while folks that
might be engaged in the criminal justice
will still kind of enter through that
door will be able to serve folks that
might not be engaged with the parole or
probation officer and hopefully maybe
avoid that connection in the first place
as a drug user however nudeson did find
treatment through the criminal justice
system he struggled for years with a
meth addiction was arrested several
times and after a two-year prison stint
for crimes related to his drug problem
he was released to a rehab program that
provided the help he needed but at that
point nudeson had spent a total of 10
years behind bars he sees the criminal
justice system as an overly blunt tool
for getting drug addicts help and thinks
measure 110 will allow others to avoid
wasting so much of their lives in prison
every time i was released from prison or
jail i always wanted to do the next
right thing i just didn't know how to do
it the deeper my addiction grew in those
windows of time where i wanted needed
help help wasn't to be found in a way
that was accessible to me it finally was
accessible
in prison which is backwards janie
gullickson who is the executive director
of a peer support group called the
mental health and addiction association
of organ also thinks there are better
ways to get drug addicts treatment than
through the criminal justice system she
overcame a meth addiction that began at
age 15 and continued until she ended up
in prison at age 36. i did want
treatment and i had been in there for a
year before i was accepted into the
program god i wish that program would
have been accessible to me before i
wasn't able to raise my five kids what
happened in portugal points to the
effectiveness of decriminalization the
country saw treatment rates increase by
32 percent within the first eight years
of enacting the policy its experience
also belies the claim of drug warriors
that decriminalization leads to more
consumption in portugal drug use rates
stayed about the same and hiv rates
decreased significantly but marshall
says he expects oregon's results to be
worse if somebody down on the street on
january 30th was using and a cop saw
them and so busted them for having drugs
out in the open they ended up in jail
they then went to court so there was a
week's period of time where their drug
use was interrupted versus the cop now
just walking right by or giving them a
ticket and walking on by and they
continue drugs the net effect of that is
is that they are using drugs more often
in a
unsafe environment and so the overdose
rates could go up in portugal overdose
rates fell after decriminalization
before trending back up a few years
later but in oregon needle exchange
providers are hopeful that the passage
of the new law will allow them to
experiment with new initiatives to drive
down overdose rates significantly clean
needle exchanges like wheelocks reduce
disease transmission and prevent fatal
overdoses because they distribute
naloxone which aborts overdoses several
studies have also shown that needle
exchanges help connect users with
substance abuse treatment programs we
regularly have clients come in and be
like haven i hate using drugs and then
the next question is okay what's next
like what are we gonna do just having
that like
non-judgmental open curious community of
people ready to answer questions and be
really honest and transparent really
helps build trust build therapeutic
relationships build hope
for people who are using drugs wheelock
also hopes the new law will allow her to
expand beyond needle exchanges and into
safe consumption spaces where users can
go to have their drugs checked for
adulterants like fentanyl and be around
workers who can help prevent overdoses
vancouver has just such a site and
there's also one operating in the united
states that doesn't have government
approval a five-year study of that
facility published in the new england
journal of medicine found that with more
than 10 000 injections there were 33
overdoses none of them fatal or
requiring hospitalization safe
consumption sites may also help to bring
the outdoor drug use and many of the
associated problems rampant on the
streets and sidewalks of portland under
a roof says wheelock no one wants to see
someone using on their front porch or in
the doorway and those people that are
using there also don't want to be seen
they don't want to be there using drugs
is something that's very private for
folks and so if they had a place where
they could do that in a safer manner
people would
while oregon will be the first in the
nation to decriminalize all drugs
following portugal's example as first in
the world neither go so far as to
legalize drug sales leaving a black
market and the crime violence and danger
associated with it fully intact
vancouver began trying to mitigate this
problem in 2020 by allowing some of its
safe consumption sites to dispense clean
opioids to drug users so they no longer
have to risk overdosing on street drugs
one argument for just not prosecuting
any drug crimes is that the black market
just makes things more dangerous is that
worth considering
have i personally pondered that sure
you know i
read about
lots of different you know philosophies
and um
that's i mean i think one step at a time
let's see how this goes how about
recreational drug users who don't have a
substance abuse problem a 2018
meta-analysis of three major national
drug use surveys found that 74 of those
who've used heroin at least once don't
ever become dependent there's always
going to be folks that are entering the
addiction system that might not need
treatment and might not want treatment
and to be honest if they're not causing
community harm
then
why should they i do think those people
are few and far between and that having
a system that provides treatment
services is the best way to go and while
oregon's 1973 marijuana
decriminalization was decades ahead of
its time proponents believe that if the
state succeeds now the wave of complete
drug decriminalization will spread
across the country much sooner nothing
launches perfectly so what are the
lessons learned maybe washington
colorado other states look at what
oregon has done and implement something
similar i think we're going to see
systems improve i think we're gonna see
people have access to care that they
currently don't have access to i think
we're gonna see less people getting
saddled with convictions that harm them
for the rest of their lives and to me
all of that is